you know I was occurring to me that one
of the things you must miss his Charles
Barkley's face uh I miss his ass he has
a flat ass for black ass like I always
look at him like would take some booty
shots or something right I do I miss
Chuck Chuck is my annoying best friend
he's funny he's annoying he's loud well
yeah I miss him I miss hitting across
from him looking at him I talked to Sir
Charles a little while ago not too long
ago and he started he started talking
some [ __ ] about you he said I don't
believe Shaq uses IcyHot
I don't think he eats at Papa John's I
don't think he's insured by the general
how do you how do you respond to that
okay the general was my first car
insurance when I was at LSU I see how I
do use I see I don't use it now because
I'm not in any aches and pains okay okay
I know I see how it works because one
day I had a Phi Bruce and the trainer
wrote it on my thigh and it rolls up to
that area to the boys and whoo-wee I was
in the shower with wood milk I had to
pour milk I had to pour milk on my
bullets to get up and I do eat a Papa
John's I'm always in the Papa John's
stop okay love the story about getting
icy hot on your testicles that was I
love that and milk is the cure if that
should happen yes
all right here's another question I got
to ask you about the advertisements
you've turned down Wheaties you won't do
an ad for Wheaties is a cereal that you
because you don't need them is there are
there cereals that you would do an ad
for if they came to you frosted flakes
is a number one choice and I'll do it
for free
so mr. frosted and mr. flakes root loops
I'm down with three loops and then I was
already on the cover of Rudy pebbles I
was on the cover of 39 bucks 40 bubbles
and then the last choice will probably
be probably me
I dig him smack remember digging smacks
thank you
what's wrong with that frogs airplane
[Music]
you know another thing I wanted to ask
you about is when I was talking to to
Berkeley I said to him look Charles I'm
6 4 I'm pretty quick I'm good with my
hands I think I think I could have made
it in the NBA he told me no way
what do you think you can't you gotta
weigh in on this you remember what I
said to you the first time I say I was
like Gigi at all looking at you on TV
you know look I'm a you look tall but
what I like talk to you you're like
right there so I don't think your sink
for I think you're six seven well that's
the hair oh good point good point
nice what are you what do you think
would you have feared me if you were
coming down and you saw me covering you
would you be afraid
oh you know you look like like look like
a pale Brian Scalabrine I thought you
were gonna say I look like the Wendy's
girl hey I'm gonna tell you one other
thing that Charles said about you he
said whenever Shaq and I get into a
basketball argument on the air Shaq
always goes to the same places which is
you don't have any rings is that what
you always say to him I sure do you
don't have one of these Charles do you
[Laughter]
Charles could never have you little baby
I'm gonna get [ __ ] from Charles now and
that's all I want to make sure that I
get the word out you got to tune in and
see Shaq life it's the new TNT series
with Shaquille O'Neal
and a sack you're hilarious thank you
very much you're always great you know I
can do anything for you okay oh it was
take care of Shack be good